so you know how once you make it and you
have money and you know you got all
these businesses lifestyle is good
you're going to be a billionaire you're
on your way to becoming a billionaire
everything's grown for you you're all
over the place your Q score is high
everybody wants to have you do stuff
with them
and and then you look at your kids and
you're talking to them and
you want them to you want to enjoy them
more because you're a little bit selfish
they're like I work so hard so I can
have them be around me I don't want them
to pay the price as much as I did you
know I was on the road I was doing this
I was doing that how do you manage
giving the council to them that they
need to hear that you heard when you
were 14 15 18 versus look man I'm worth
a few hundred million I don't got to
tell this guy to pay the price today so
I have two different conversations
I have three daughters and three sons
Three Sons
when you're 18 get out
get out
now while you're out
better get one degree
two degrees before you come messing with
me
like I'm not just gonna be funding stuff
because you want to do it
I did to them like somebody did to me
when they turned 18 I went to the bank
because I spent a million dollars in one
day and the guy gave me a book The
dummies got to starting your own
business I gave them all the same book
I said here you go you're a man now make
a decision but really never want to come
mess with me I need one or two degrees
not the lady is a little different hey
baby you can stay as long as you want
I love you sweetheart no boys don't
worry about getting married
and you know the conversation I have my
six children I said look we don't need
another basketball player your daddy's
crazy you don't need to be like me I
need a hedge fund operator I need a CEO
I need I need something else so uh
I don't like using this words but I have
six perfect children I don't have any
problems one is a executive marketer for
Pepsi she already has a bachelor's
another one has his bachelor's he's good
looking like me he's a model
uh
my youngest son is in a g league and I
got two on College and I got one left in
high school that I'll be done
[Applause]
[Music]
uh while we're while we're on this topic
hold on what is that thing
hahaha
that's nice
[Applause]
is that my Puerto Ricans doing that
oh yeah Puerto Rico it's it's cowbells
is what it is oh Sacramento from Texas
yes USA
okay okay USA USA hey everybody we're
all one
this place will go crazy any second
you lit them up
okay
what is that a chance
everyone's got their own chance okay
good
I love it all right come on come on come
on come on come on come on
so so
when it when it comes down to the way
your dad raised you are you raising your
boys in any different way than the way
he raised you no it's different okay he
was uh very tough on me and I can handle
it
I give my kids the eye spanking
that look right there if I give that
look to my girls they're done for a week
that look like that if I give that look
to my boys they know I'm not playing
never had to spank them never had to
touch him up but and it's and I'm more
of the I'm more of the friend parent
let the moms do the discipline and I'm
more of that hey you can't do this don't
do that and I like because remember
I'm already
not with them
because I'm working out and not with
them because I'm in business meetings
I'm not with them because I'm over here
buying companies I'm not with them
because I'm doing this I can't come home
and be the bad guy all the time so we
had a game in my house when he was
Andrew's house it was
they knew that as soon as I come into
the house I'm not Daddy I'm a dog man
you want to know what dog man is as soon
as I open the door I'm a wild dog and I
start chasing
so
yeah
I'm gonna fight him and I beat them up
and I throw them on the bed so then
after an hour of that then my mom's been
like you know he didn't do this and I
have to pull him to the side hey man you
know like I can't always come in and you
know be the bad guy so I let the moms
you know discipline them like that
[Music]